obrigado jeans
quantos de vocês ou quanto você acredita
que um disco pode mudar uma vida uma
geração o mundo em meados de 1983
um garotinho chamado clube campo não
mais conhecido como cuco ranking foi o
responsável por iniciar uma
transformação mundial quando pediu para
que seu pai comprasse o lp sex machine
de james brown
eu moro ali que ela falou um garotinho
mudou o mundo com sexo mach de james
brown
esse garotinho é alguém aqui já ouviu
falar em corrupção por exemplo
opa temos aqui um record sabe que
geralmente em hip hop já melhorou já me
sinto em casa
pra quem nunca ouviu falar que brota uma
cultura que nasceu em meados de 1973 em
nova york no bairro do bronx e nasceu
especificamente ou resumidamente para
combater o racismo à violência dentro
das comunidades negras americanas o que
tem de tão especial na cultura hip hop
essa cultura foi responsável por dar a
oportunidade para as pessoas dentro
dessa como dessas comunidades para que
essas pessoas começassem a trabalhar um
resgate social cultural isso através da
arte e depois de um longo prazo
começassem até a trabalhar ascensão
social
a gente fala e hip hop
a gente fala em arte ponto arte a
cultura hip hop é formada por quatro
elementos artísticos
o primeiro que eu dj o segundo o mpe se
nessa categoria d m se entra o biel
brown e às vezes
natura que chama o nome sabe ana ferraz
mãe chorando artigo indefinido o som ele
se o cara que vai através das palavras
de jaime se fazer a música rap a música
da cultura hip hop mas não para por aí
não tenho de boyle grupos são os
dançarinos do break
o grafiteiro raiter que dentro das
estéticas artistas é responsável pelas
tags bombs while the style 3d
só que toda manifestação artística é
resultado de uma catarse e toda a
catarse necessita do que uma consciência
para acontecer
alguém tem idéia de quando a consciência
da cultura hip hop começou a se formar
já ficou mais difícil do que no bronx né
é impossível falar de hip hop se a gente
não fala de violência
não falar de racismo é impossível falar
de hip hop sem falar de pobreza sem
falar de repressão e sem falar de falta
de perspectiva no futuro são as capas
dos jornais quando mataram martin luther
king e malcom ex mas é impossível falar
de hip hop sem falar de esperança sem
falar de empoderamento sem falar de
reestruturação social cultural é
impossível falar de hip hop sem atitude
e sem luta
quando a gente começa a estudar a
formação da consciência da cultura hip
hop
a gente começa a perceber que essa
formação está inconsciente na comunidade
negra desde a época da escravidão e que
só resolveu se manifestar disse k mente
cor em 1973 um garotinho chamado clicam
mais conhecido como curran que chegou
por seu pai e disse 'pai escola um disco
pra mim
qual disco sexo achim de james brown por
isso obrigado james e esse garotinho foi
responsável por iniciar uma revolução
sem nem alegado ele resolveu fazer uma
festa de aniversário da irmã dele nesse
lugar
henrique abrão 1520 e essa festa marcou
o início de uma cultura que foi
responsável por transformar não só os
estados unidos não só as comunidades
negras americanas mas todas ao redor do
mundo e depois outros tipos de
comunidade
esse é o flyer rolezinho porque é
importante essa festa porque nessa festa
o gueto americano começou a perceber que
o jovem negro latini periférico dentro
da festa estava vivo e isso pra época
titio protesto sorriso o corpo sorriso
político está ligada esse garotinho que
já não é mais tão garotinho é
considerado até hoje vivo
o pai do hip hop esse outro aqui tupac
shakur foi um cara que disse o seguinte
eu não sou o cara que vai mudar o mundo
mas talvez eu seja o cara que vai
despertar idéias das pessoas que vão
meu nome é marcelo de souza dormem mais
conhecido como marcelo gol eu venho de
um bairro chamado ipiranga e desde
pequena aprendi que o que você quer ser
quando crescer
na verdade nunca foi uma pergunta pra
gente foi um desafio
salve timão salvou domino a maioria dos
meus amigos não tão vivo pra me ver aqui
hoje
agora é a hora do clichê são bacanas
ic10 o hip hop salvou minha vida
em meados de 2006 eu esse camarada julio
cesar mais conhecido como flo m se
estávamos na seguinte situação falta de
perspectiva falta de dinheiro falta de
um monte de coisa seja na merda a gente
tá fazendo tinha gente resolveu fazer
já dentro do movimento hip hop
resolvemos formar um coletivo musical
chamado áfrica kids grupo alguns meses
depois 20 pessoas e uma pode briga que
se imagina 20 moleque tentando decidir
alguma para não rolar
a gente resolveu fundar a tradicional
batalha de freestyle do santa cruz
ó
para quem nunca ouviu falar foi estael é
a manifestação musical do improviso
dentro do rap ou seja me se pega o
microfone foi a rapaziada para trocar
uma idéia na forma de rima uma batalha
significa uma disputa entre esses dois
índices
e aí rola aquela espiadinha você tão
magro que olha com os dois ouros no
buraco da fechadura todo mundo dá risada
18 de fevereiro de 2006 a batata santa
cruz respira a primeira vez disso já foi
o suficiente para mudar o cenário do hip
hop nacional
por que você pensa nisso porque disse
sábado mas nunca ouvi falar que esse
bagulho sem dinheiro apenas movidos pela
vontade de fazer alguma coisa em relação
ao rap em relação à nossa vida porque as
oportunidades negativa estavam sempre
batendo na porta
reunimos alguns amigos fizemos a
primeira batalha e ela hoje é
responsável por dar nome a maioria dos
caras que estão em alta no cenário do
hip hop nacional
rachid m se esse que vos fala de
chinelinho de dedo e o emicida ali
com o tempo a gente começou por ser o
seguinte
aquilo não era só uma roda de moleque um
ano outro tira aquilo era um ponto
cultural
mais que isso aquilo começou a trabalhar
nos moleques a oportunidade de se
expressar quem nunca teve voz agora tem
voz é ouvido pessoas pararam para ouvir
o que você está falando
mais que isso esses jovens começaram a
se sentir parte de um grupo
o crime é um grupo
o tráfico de drogas é um grupo que a
batalha da santa cruz começou a fazer
com que esses muleques fizessem parte de
outro grupo não mais da estatística que
morre antes dos 30min da estatística que
passa numa faculdade isso é real porque
a gente começou a coletar histórias
a gente viveu essas histórias moleque
que não gostava de ler o diário escola
agora levar um dicionário na mochila eu
levei o dicionário no cinema
nunca passei a letra mas eu levei o
dicionário na mochila real é real ou
perguntava da mãe por ser todo o sábado
isso fez com que as pessoas criassem
identificação criassem
amizades criassem troca de experiências
todo sábado desde 2006 a gente está no
mesmo lugar completando dez anos
essa é a batalha do santa cruz timidez
introversão medo de se expressar o medo
de dizer o que pensa
medo de público medos medos - ali
primeiro que as pessoas a se envolverem
perdiam esses meses depois não são mais
números são indivíduos cada um era
chamado pelo nome pelo apelido por mais
voado que seja o google goggles é
conhecido quando eu comecei eu digo isso
foi quando eu comecei na batalha do
santa cruz eu era um desses garotos todo
acuado com medo de me expressar com medo
de dizer o que pensava eu era um desses
garotos que foi acolhido pelo que hop e
que conseguiu criar junto com outros
garotos que também foram acolhidos algo
que acolhesse garotos que estavam como a
gente teve um dia
perdidos quando comecei a perceber isso
entende o que button dj na mesma época
do corpo entendeu com as leis em 1 a 1 e
que ele criou o hip hop tem um poder
transformador na vida de cada pessoa que
paga que começa a fazer parte desse
movimento
e aí eu pensei nisso é muito pra
mim deixar só que só ali então cria um
projeto chamado infinity class uma
história sobre a ótica do hip hop
eu comecei a dar aula de história nunca
fui professor mas o que eu consegui
perceber que a música criar uma conexão
com essa molecada e que eu conseguia
falar com o moleque ele entender mais do
que às vezes ele entende o professor de
história doido todo tatuado fala de
martin luther king um valor que isso
iria dar bom iria funcionar
o primeiro convite miguel de cervantes
uma das escolas mais caras senão a mais
cara em são paulo
entrei dei minha aula e aí eu percebi o
seguinte eu tenho na mão
o colégio mais caro que são paulo é um
pólo mas é preciso jogar no outro lado
comecei a peregrinar pelo estado de são
paulo bater na porta da escola
após dar uma aula tal fala de hip hop
mas fala de história principalmente
história negra que quase ninguém conta
é uma página o livro da história negra
no nos livros de história
e aí eu levava um livro ae
o mais louco do hip hop que ele consegue
falar por gerações
essa aqui é uma classe de forma
professoras formandas da unip e essa
aqui é a sala de aula da mesma marca e
falei a molecada haiti não faz um revés
quando eu pensei no pólo oposto
eu vi que as escolas de periferia ainda
não era um o fundo do poço
existe um lugar muito mais difícil de
ser trabalhado em junho de 2014 foi
convidado depois de bater muito na porta
ele deixa até uma vizinha buscar abrigo
cheguei num lugar chamado fundação casa
ou antiga febem lugar onde adolescentes
que cumprem medidas sócio educativas
dentro da fundação casa o que eu
percebia que o hip hop era um excelente
veículo para mim propor discussões sobre
o machismo sobre racismo sobre feminismo
sobre genocídio da comunidade negra
sobre como empreender a esses muleques
que eles tinham para que eles tenham
orgulho de quem eles são
porque a vida inteira ele escutou não
ele escutou você não vai
você não vai conseguir o ibope falava o
que você vai ser difícil para todo mundo
ali tá tá fácil você sequer mamão então
você vai chegar fazer não só tem que
lutar igual todo mundo lutou e aí eu
comecei a trabalhar na fundação casa foi
que eu percebi que o hip hop é uma
ferramenta maravilhosa mas que ele não
funciona por exemplo sem políticas
públicas
então a minha taxa de reincidência é
muito alto
a falta de reintegração social a falta
de reinserção à falta de educação faz
com que às vezes eu entro numa sala olha
se fala assim lucas sete vezes num ano é
meu grau nome adicional no facebook
ouvir seu amigo não voltava pra canal
o senhor é um desacerto do mundão toy de
novo sem políticas públicas difícil mas
acreditar é isso
é tá lá e falar por lucas mil vezes que
ele vai conseguir que basta ter força de
vontade de trabalhar pra isso
isso muitas vezes significa trombar com
um deles no corredor e ele se parar
falou assim ah senhor meu grau essa
idéia
vou fazer igual ao senhor você alguém na
vida sair daqui voltar pra contar uma
história
você pensa eu vou cobrar mas que se foca
na cobrança unificada e shows e cobrados
e não fizer então ele vai fazer assim eu
espero é quando a gente tá ali dentro é
uma realidade quando ele sai de lá ele
volta com o mesmo lugar ele volta com as
mesmas fotos de perspectiva
já encontrei um com a carteira de
trabalho na mão isso foi meu grau
o hip hop me ensinou a venda semelhante
como irmão o hip hop ensinou a respeitar
e semelhante me ensinou a me entender
e mais que isso transformou a minha vida
me deu a oportunidade de chegar preciso
moleque falar que é capaz porque alguns
anos atrás era pra mim tá numa cadeira
daquelas e eu virei pra eles e falei foi
uma escolha que eu fiz a única diferença
entre eu e vocês foi que eu escolhi está
com o microfone na mão como a quando
penso nisso
eu entendo que o hip hop mais que uma
ferramenta é um estilo de vida
eu entendo uma frase muito louca do
mundo de chamado grand master kessy que
diz que o hip hop não criou nada o hip
hop recriou tudo ea partir disso eu tô
aqui eu entendo duas coisas a primeira é
que hoje vocês foram sensibilizados pela
cultura hip hop
a segunda é que eu tive a oportunidade
de hoje conhecer cada um de vocês e que
cada um de vocês talvez seja a ideia que
o pac disse que ia despertar para mudar
o mundo
portanto nesse palco eu sou só um mas eu
não sou apenas um
aqui eu sou hip hop o piso xadrez
o popping o locking m esperança são
vocês eu sou o dj as picapes as agulhas
os riscos a primeira loja que corra que
comprou um par de discos
sou mestre de cerimônia que eternizou o
tempo eo espaço os franceses e
brasileiros chuva ringue oito compassos
rotina
rock mick e eu sou o mec é tron edson
ávila que o dias não quer sou style
freestyle de hollywood salt dons sound
system mel five tags bombs eu sobrevivi
como o tite la basque a eu sou quem é
quem já vê quem ainda vai chegar a
roland emmerich já de noite oca hálito
parte de hatice can has nast é esse mas
eu posso afirmar uma parada
eu sou todos eles eles se a gente não
são nada só de nadir saboya dizem primo
gramas tg e gritei foi de pagode e hip
hop
orei op pitt rock os bloc party em tirar
blog da moda os muleques clássicos igual
a actaris old school new school céus no
endereço e nice sou velho vai acabar do
sulo m se lá e viu em ganhou o mundo na
emissão o cidadão kane
eu sou bambaataa grand master flash
adobe flash malley mal de mondé se os
flashes e o que faz do mundo interno
show design prix can't slow minha droga
dela soltem black panthers black blá blá
gol
notorious big como tentativa de joilson
do dome www ou pode me chamar de flor eu
sou você é
nós somos seremos e fomos sejamos
vivamos o rei ghob dá certo temos que
dar valor aos amores diz que seus
rancores perdoam os pecadores ignorar os
rumores se libertar dos senhores se
lembrar dos tambores andar armado foi
inevitável que a sua arte flores
o rap é e sempre foi uma coisa só é
possível devido ao rápido e não incide
pro esquece essas de barbie indústria
mídia preconceito que está falando que o
rap tem que ser feito desse ou daquele
jeito
agora discutem quem se vendeu quem está
vendido geralmente quem julgou se perdeu
ou nasceu perdida é só voltar o começo
que certas de gana está the ground por
um salão de sódio becker de quererem
leve biquíni em são paulo onde não seja
billboard não seja stop se você chegar
lá graças a deus mas seja o de replay da
rap do ons top 10 e flex
dayan pistas da bucha babies que o hip
hop esquece o
a extensão da polícia porque é por essas
que speed meus amigo e bial é simples
pra eles tanto faz se a gente se matar
entre nós ou viciados em crack
pra eles eram a menos para nós foi do
pac que pilota uma cultura que se vive
eu acredito que essa sinergia hoje em
comum tec tex
nós somos o hip hop todos nós um som
obrigado